these people are out to get their daily
supplies this road connects 40 villages
and is a major lifeline for the town of
rangia it's been underwater for nearly a
week so i had dinner racial it's been
more than six to seven days since the
flooding started in the area the water
came into our house a day before
yesterday my house was submerged at
night
heavy flooding in assam state has
affected more than four million people
thousands of villages are flooded and
many people have been forced to flee
their homes while heavy rains usually
fall at this time of year in assam areas
like rangia haven't seen this kind of
flooding in many years many people were
unprepared and they're concerned that
the main source of water is being
polluted and could bring disease
at least 150 000 people have been moved
to camps the government has set up
centers to distribute food and supplies
health workers are conducting malaria
tests
this relief camp is in kamrok districts
while conducting health checkups for all
those living in the relief camp while
also providing the people with required
medicine while mostly getting fever
cases we have not found symptoms of any
other disease here
evacuations are underway the military is
also rescuing people but they're being
hampered by constant rain and rising
water levels
people from polo bhangra were coming to
sell milk and vegetables here nine
people were travelling in the boat which
sank in the river
four of them have been rescued
the monsoon season began early this
month and rainfall has already broken
records that's making people anxious
about what they'll face before it ends
bhavni mithal al-jazeera rangya in
northeast india